hi i'm alex and this is my recipe for
chocolate cookie crust peanut butter pie
[Music]
so this fun fact is actually one of my
all-time favorite desserts as a kid
my sister can attest we used to make
this all the time it was the best we
keep it in the freezer
eat it all week long oh my god it's so
good i know it seems basic but trust me
there is nothing better than this like
frozen peanut butter pie i used to make
this pie with
a graham cracker crumb crust which you
can absolutely do
but for this tasty video i decided to
switch it up and
use chocolate sandwich cookies so the
crust is super simple it's just some
cookie crumbs and butter
and then you line the pan with that and
then you're just gonna bake that quickly
to set so now on to the delicious part
every part is delicious but this is like
the most delicious part so this filling
is almost like a frozen mousse kind of
thing so we're lightening up the peanut
butter with cream cheese and whipped
cream and powdered sugar
gets like like light and fluffy texture
so we're making like a peanut butter
mousse so you definitely want to use
softened cream cheese here
cream cheese is a little bit tricky to
work with because you can often get
pretty lumpy so we're breaking down the
process of mixing up this filling so
then you're going to pour that filling
right onto your already baked cookie
crust
smooth that out
get a nice little design on there you
could like kind of like add some little
things
you know what i mean like add some
swirls like do you it's like an art
project almost you know
style
gangnam style
riya says it looks like a gangnam style
wait how do they do that again is it
that do you know the dance
stuff oh no it's like that right
so this is what you want to do to your
pie
so wopo gangnam style your pie and then
you're just gonna pop it in the freezer
to set the hardest part because you have
to wait there's like something that
happens in the freezer magic
or science
where this pie sets but like
it's so much better than even just like
a cooled pie like the frozen aspect of
it it's like the perfect like silky
ice creamy yet not quite as dense
consistency and now all you have left to
do is top it so i just spanked myself
so i topped this with a little bit more
of those crushed cookie crumbs that we
used for the base but again if you were
using the graham cracker crust you could
do whatever you want you could even just
not top it with anything because it's
delicious as is but there you go
if you love me as much as i love this
pie
subscribe to my youtube channel
actually fun fact this is what the team
made for me my first birthday at tasty
because i knew how much i love this pie
[Music]
you